entre louise et son violon ça a tout de
suite été le coup de foudre
son instrument elle a hérité de son
grand-père qui le lui a légué
lorsqu'elle avait 14 ans
soixante ans plus tard sa musique
résonne encore je vais ouvert il y avait
ni chevalet ni cordier ni mentonnière ni
cheville ni cordes tout était en pièces
dans la boîte avec le violon et j'ai
tout remonté j'ai mis des cordes et je
les ai essayé
et j'ai adoré le son du violon un son
que l'adolescente a voulu faire partager
au public du concours france musique est
une manière pour elle de se confronter
au monde de la musique professionnelle
ça permet de me prouver quelque chose
quelque part d'avoir fait ce concours
prouvé quoi si si jeune si gta à la
hauteur c'est si c'était pas trop risqué
de partir dans le métier de musicien si
j'avais les capacités
la jeune musicienne jongle aisément avec
son autre passion le poney entouré de
ses parents elle leur fait régulièrement
partager ses mélodies et un poney qui
adore la musique dès que je joue il
arrive à la barre hier il est hyper
attentif à la musique il a été versé
dans la musique quand il était petit sa
passion louise la nourrit depuis son
plus jeune âge ses professeurs de
musique son entourage mais aussi son
instrument l'ont vraiment convaincu à
poursuivre dans cette voie c'est pas
pour rien si j'ai fait violence
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir ce violon
c'est peut-être lui faut que j'aille
plus loin vous j'en ai envie
destiné au simple concours de
circonstances force est de constater que
l'esprit bienveillant du grand père de
louise veille toujours sur elle elle qui
espère remporter le prix tant convoité
du jury
[Musique]